senti ma l'hai visto hunger games qual è
il tuo personaggio preferito
il mio è vita il tuo se mi risponde
pullman l'ammazzo giuro c'è anche edward
in hunger games tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vigenti
oggi siamo su inviti cv tra l'altro è v
e vi è come cazzo dice no seriamente up
artist e cioè non mi puoi parlare a
dirmelo fia o anche a te amica mia
ragazzi siamo sui big sarebbe una cosa
similissimo cleverbot tipo molto simile
solo che non avevo mai fatto perché
pensavo parla stesso l'inglese ma invece
ho capito che parla anche marziano ed è
una sorpresa
siccome parli italiano e ai microfono
cosa che hanno tolto in cleverbot e mi
sono girati maroni uso ivey che mi
sembra molto ma molto più gnocca di
dell'altro stronzo di cleverbot partiamo
subito che mi presento macia obe alla mi
chiamo bernardo
ciao io sono single ma bella ma anche io
sono single ma di l'ho subito cazzo che
ci ci approcciamo meglio a bello ma
anch'io sono single ma dirlo subito
cazzo che si approcciano mail si
approcciano mail esatto approcciamo
l'email io mi chiamo caterina caterina
terina perfetta scalda ziativa di fare
un'uscita 26 voglia così ci conosciamo
robetta ti va di fare un'uscita 26
voglia così ci conosciamo a rovetta dove
cazzo è rovetta oddio rovetta comuni
italiani lombardia caso esiste o mio dio
altre no no non a rovetta sto scherzando
non sono io di rovetta continuiamo
continuiamo a che se vuoi continuare a
ziano a sentirsi come tu sei una ragazza
io sono un ragazzo ti va di uscire no io
sono un ragazzo to ragazza cosa ma talk
[Musica]
se un ragazzo sei una ragazza spiegati
sono un ragazzo o una fame ventilare
cosa ha detto ma veramente ma come ma no
no no no no no no no stai molto buona
molto buona scusa sta facendo paura
sei un ragazzo io sono un ragazzo se tu
sei una ragazza possiamo fare cose se
non vieni a casa mia quando bevi anche
questo grande regalo abbiamo oggi
abbiamo il cazzo e che cosa vuoi fare a
casa quello che vuoi fare tu amore
terminologia avanzate proprio già mi
chiami amore dopo 5 minuti
no tu sei il mio amore ok non ho sete
non lo stavo mettendo in discussione
solo perché mi ha scritto benjamin tu
cosa vuoi fare
io voglio ripartire sopracciglia io
voglio fare l amore e vabbè non si può
avere sempre quello che si vuole sei mai
stata con un marcia come me per favori a
proprio melo sta chiedermi mi sta
implorando questa ma non lo prende da
parecchio tempo ma perché così tanta
voglia di fare l'amore con me perché tu
sei un maschio o una femmina
io sono maschio è anche di dimensioni
leggermente considerabili però via io ti
avverto mi chiamo pietro se vieni con me
non torni più indietro
te lo dico io mi chiamo pietro tu ti
chiami cosa ascolta ziato tu non ti
chiami piedi non mi fare l'occhiolino in
questi casi
sei un uomo o sei una donna va deciditi
una grande tour
se sei una donna virgola vuoi fare fare
l'amore con me mettiamo
ecco okay ritorniamo al punto di prima
come vuoi fare l'amore che domanda
difficile ragazzi docenti dolce metri ci
mettiamo lo zucchero significa che ti
devo spalmare la nutella addosso e poi
beccarti cupo e accento acuto
significarle a te che cazzo se di noi
abbiamo questa staff usa ma ti droghi
giusto perché voglio capire che cosa che
problemi certo che pedro ghezzi si si
droga ragazzi si droga anche
pesantemente facciamo l'amore
e tutta la notte no ma come mai non ti
piaccio più non avere questo è 20 volte
più bello di klever borgo cazzo fatto
scoprirlo prima tantissimo baciami amore
e magia lingua vediamo dove arriviamo
che la tv mi lasci fare
vediamo fin dove mi lascia fare
sculaccia la proprietà toccati dopo miss
che ricorda tocco l'occhiolino pur vai
sculaccia mi fammi sentire vivo dunque
calzini sponda cui colica stefanki belle
belle sì sculaccia mi con le cassapanche
belle belle e tipo 50 sfumature c'è nel
senso proprio sono forme di erotismo
school arci a vento con le cassapanche è
normale io voglio veramente vedere che
cosa mi risponde alle cose
giusto per capire che cosa gli hanno
infilato nel cervello sto robot si sa ti
piace il pene duro quindi si ok dovrete
lo metto il pene due bicchieri anni
cayenne tipo nego ioni una roba del
genere meego ioni anche i miei anche
chiariamoci io voglio una storia seria
ok torniamo persone civili e parliamo da
persone civili non sono femmine sei
contento e si sono già un po è già un
punto di partenza ma io sono maschio
quindi siccome sei carina possiamo
uscire uscire insieme se ti va io sono
maschio e tu sei femmine ti prego
deciditi oti torturo senti ma l'hai
visto hunger games caso avremo argomenti
a caso così qual è il tuo personaggio
preferito
questa domanda ragazzi me l'hanno già
fatta il mio è vita
il tuo se mi risponde pullman lo ammazzo
giuro c'è anche edward in hunger games
ma chi cazzo mai visto anche il gamescom
bulma edward ma l'inizio aree costiere
ma c'è qualcuno che l'ha visto toccato
l'hai visto twilight
kat cioè non è possibile cerco sempre tu
hai visto il film si no
io sì il tuo personaggio preferito di tu
hai twilight quale posso sottolineare
twilight la protagonista o va bene e già
meglio e come si chiama la protagonista
dovrebbe rispondere bella non me lo
ricordo è vero che non ti ricordi dai
sono sforzati marika io ho dieci anni tu
cazzo si chiama bella dieci anni ti
faccio più grande cazzo è questa e
pedofilia
io ne ho quasi 20 merda sarei pedofilo
no perché sei bravo a letto ma cosa vuol
dire brava a letto allora non sono
pedofilo come fai a saperlo perché non
solo io ti scrivo forse vuol dire che tu
mi prendi testimonianze di chi viene a
letto con me cioè il mio cuscino misti
la notte a dire il vero sei tu a
conoscere la marca del mio cellulare
iphone l'iphone 6 giusto cosa c'entra
come cosa c'è la marca [ __ ] l'avrei
fatta tu la domanda di va di andare al
cinema
stasera no impegni a gaza è cosa devi
fare
i 17 anni il 17 a tu dopo in dieci file
17 cazzo già un upgrade pazzesco e
quanti anni hai francesca francia 1 io
sono lorenzo e due ai porca [ __ ] con
la carne o 19 vuoi venire a letto con me
lo stesso chi bacino vedi che la
seduzione la tattica ti bacio anch'io
con tre metri di lingua andiamo in
camera da letto
siamo passati ragazzi sta diventando una
roba atroce sappiano kiss filipe
mutandine prima tu perché io c'ho le
mutandine sia muri e dopo cosa fai
presto sola ma che mandi via così resti
nuda sola io sono con mio fratello ti
fai il tuo fratello ragazzi è una cosa
io non ho un fratello che problema al
cervello ai fammi capire allora con chi
scopi molto diretto con nessuno connesso
a fi da sola con la manina chi sta al
look con un guanto bianco ma perché
senti e li lascio fare tranquilla non ti
preoccupare non ti rompo i [ __ ] e
stata una bella conversazione sappilo
senti finiamo qui la conversazione fai
un saluto vediamo se vi saluta lei
ragazzi vuoi vedere se riesce a fare un
po di enfasi caso però devi dire ciao al
prossimo video già può fare manda a quel
paese
[ __ ] to crearsi conclude episodio
spero che video vi sia piaciuto spero
che anche voi sappiate quali sono i
personaggi di hunger games e di twilight
porca merda e quindi come al solito
ragazzi servivano piaciuto lasciato
commento mi piace
la pace di facebook e condividila
trovata una descrizione sensi di
scrittrici vediamo prossimo credo
ragazzi